Thanks can you hear me all right thank
you for coming all the way to Iceland my
presentation thank you for waking up so
early this morning I mean talking about
if one laptop per child started today
how JavaScript d would it be we're a
bunch of JavaScript people we want to
kind of do a retrospective to see what
happened in the past and then maybe I'll
be able to use that to convince you that
we can do a little preview of the future
yet to come so they gave me a laser
pointer okay so I work with one laptop
per child kind of in different roles
teacher developer volunteer never got
like a check from one laptop per child
proper but working for these regional
organizations so I worked in uganda
uruguay haiti and the marshall islands
out in the Pacific between 2010 and 2013
usually a couple months at a time meet
with different people go to the school
get the laptop project setup and a lot
of people when they see me they see the
laptop they ask what happened to OLPC
seemed like it was very popular very
famous we have one of the laptops in the
crowd going around so keep it moving and
people saw it and wondered what happened
did it ever get to kids what it was it
used for does it really work to really
answer that question we have to go back
in time back to the year two thousand
five eleven years ago if you think about
it and the announcement was very major I
don't know if you would all remember
this but the announcement what they were
first starting it they have Kofi Annan
from the UN they have Nicholas
Negroponte e founder of the mem IT media
lab presenting this prototype a
hand-cranked hundred-dollar laptop is
the goal they would only actually start
delivering laptops in 2007-2008 and at
the idea laptop for kids was actually
very absurd idea laptops were expensive
they're very fragile I found this
article from ZDNet that they were proud
the average price of a laptop had
dropped from fourteen hundred dollars to
eleven hundred dollars here comes
someone saying I'm going to make a
laptop for just one hundred at the time
if you want to get some tech for your
kid you might get this leap pad
it has kind of some clever features
there's like a smart pen that knows the
numbers your kid is writing but not an
actual full computer the ipod looked a
little bit like this and people were
saying why not give people an iPod it
has lots of audiobooks and lessons and
the belief was you know they partnered
with all these very free software
Richard Stallman types who said you know
educational devices should have a
terminal it shouldn't be controlling you
you should have full access to the
computer in some way it shouldn't just
need a device for consumption and so one
of the first criticisms that people said
right away laptop is a hundred dollars
or two hundred dollars is this an
effective like is going to affect
education properly by the dollar and in
fact I'm going to say no in fact people
study this very well and they know full
well what are the most effective ways to
change education for your money and
they're very well known very well
research the first is a deworming pills
every three to five years the kid takes
these pills they don't get parasites
second sanitary pads for girls third bed
nets so you don't get malaria these are
very well understood if you want to
donate money to these kind of causes
please do they're very effective for a
small amount of money and they don't
involve school at all if you think about
it it just matters that the kids are
healthy and going to school and not
missing classes it makes a lot of sense
but in the world in the real world that
we live in you know people have
technology I go to these countries and
people are using smartphones already and
there's risk if the technology is only
developed in wealthy countries and the
technology is used worldwide that
there's a great number of people who
have no access to the economy and the
control over the devices they use and in
my experience people really want to use
and learn technology like when I was in
Uganda I met a kid who was learning
Excel out of a textbook he doesn't have
a computer he's just learning you know
in the Edit menu of cut copy paste I
heard about a school in Rwanda where the
teacher has a C++ book and then the
teacher copies the program onto the
chalkboard
and the students copy the program down
their notebooks like you would never
expect those people to actually know C++
because they're learning it in this very
convoluted way that's how high the
demand is how important is to people
that are using this technology to learn
it and take control of it for themselves
so the laptop and products that followed
it is filling a very real gap and
availability to make our technology
world more accessible and equitable
going back to the laptop the first
version of it had just one gigabyte of
solid-state memory on an SD card and
there were no solid state hard solid 8
laptops at the time so very exciting a
Nicholas Negroponte he does a demo where
he tosses it a little bit like a frisbee
but he probably has like a hundred of
them at home I only like one here in
Iceland so please don't uh this screen
can go from color to like a black and
white pink kind of screen which is very
readable even in direct sunlight the
ideas like there's some outdoor schools
or maybe they're going to be able to
read it and direct sunlight a bit
water-resistant they only have USD and
SD card inputs there's a video online
where when it first came out where
they're typing on the keyboard as it's
like a faucet is pouring water down on
the keyboard they're very excited to
make it water resistant and they work
very hard to source the very lowest cost
pieces so in some cases that was a very
poor decision there was touch pads that
didn't work very well they also agreed
not to sell it outright in the United
States so they wouldn't be competing
with other laptops using the same parts
which would end up to be a problem later
so today we're kind of in a different
environment year and a half ago I was
back in Haiti and a building they've
been destroyed in the earthquake has
been rebuilt and there's this factory in
a sense called I think they call it
hence com kind of unusual name but
there's a system now where there's a
chinese company will they'll do a
program where they'll set up they
manufacture the pieces in china and they
set up an assembly plant in local
countries so haiti north korea other
countries you wouldn't really expect to
be manufacturing tablets
control that final assembly step so
today if I were setting up a project I
wouldn't go through a whole trouble of
building you know a brand new hardware
from scratch instead I would say look
you can go to this office they'll give
you a tablet you don't have to smuggle
computers into the country anymore and
it works if the screen breaks you can
bring it back for repairs they also have
some solar panels and phone chargers and
things they make a lot of really
interesting stuff there another really
good idea about that came with the
laptop project was this idea of a mesh
network even today this is really
difficult if someone said okay by the
end of the day we need to have a mesh
network with everyone's phones connected
I don't know if we could do it like we
were smart people but in small clusters
it's doable but then as it expands out
it's very difficult in fact the largest
deployment plans say ball and org why
just in this operating system that they
use they just disabled mesh networking
all together but when it does work I
mean you have to understand these
teachers have never used Google Docs so
it's like oh well they're typing and
it's typing on someone else's computer
people were very excited so then finally
we have the operating system many people
they turn on their like what is this is
this a real computer so it has linux as
fedora with the support of red hat and
then they added on top of this an MIT
Media Lab sort of dream quest called
sugar and so the idea was I think this
comes into play later but the idea was
they could be deploying this laptop in
countries where people are not with very
young kids who aren't literate yet or
countries where there's some countries
where even some teachers aren't literate
to the full extent so they were saying
let's make an interface that's all about
these colorful icons it makes kids want
to try different things and there's
still new releases to this there's one
laptop per child and there's a separate
nonprofit called sugar labs so you can
get this as a separate deployment and
today if I said I'm going to do an
education project and I'm going to start
by building my own operating system you
would be like Nick get out of here don't
do it but
time Android was just a feature phone
operating system there wasn't really an
option you had to pay for stuff so the
idea of there being an operating system
that would be easy for kids to use was
important then and then now it's kind of
like oh no like you know we've made this
huge investment so MIT vision like why
are they making the heart the laptop so
sturdy why are they making the laptop
have its own operating system with these
colorful icons is there picturing at the
time you know these very rural schools
outdoors sometimes in sub-saharan Africa
in Afghanistan Pakistan where this
picture is taken they actually did a lot
of talking with Gaddafi in Libya sort of
a awkward time for us politics at the
time but they thought that Gaddafi might
buy millions of these or maybe there
would be a state in India that would buy
a million of them and then the other
states would start competing with them
but that never worked out there was
never like a massive multi-million
laptop order so instead of reaching the
hundred-dollar laptop target they don't
have that level of production so it's
closer to two hundred dollars for the
laptop they were thinking about
illiteracy the there's a quote that gets
used a lot about if they put a hundred
books on 100 laptops you would have
10,000 books and that's better than we
would have in our school library but you
know like is one kid going to have all
the biology textbooks and one kid can
have all the French poetry like it
doesn't really make sense it turns out
in a real classroom environment you want
kids doll the same book so they can read
together and write their notes and so so
not just like have each kids struggling
with their own book that no one's heard
of and then it turned out it wasn't
about sub-saharan Africa it turned out
the largest participants in the project
were or why and Peru I think each
country is bought about a million of the
laptops and over over time and so each
kid in Uruguay gets it like they can
bring it home because your neighbor's
kid has 12 there's no danger of being
stolen you can take it to the post
office and get it repaired look it's a
whole national system and everyone's
very proud of it you see the laptop was
announced at just the right time where
they want to roll out public Wi-Fi to
public too
public spaces and schools across the
country and they said the best way to do
that is put in the schools give the kids
laptops a lot of the kids parents are
using the internet for the first time
using these laptops it just ended up
being different from how they envisioned
it so it went from being a sub-saharan
Africa project to Latin America
middle-income country project the
software itself you write in Python I'll
get to that in a minute but you have
sort of a custom activity structure that
you zip up into a dot XO file because
the laptops called XO 1 X 0 2 they did
not originally include flash or mp3
encoders they said don't you know the
wonders of open source and open formats
everyone will use audios it seems
strange now like obviously kids are
going to go to youtube and be
disappointed but at the time YouTube
came out 2006 they were designing it
2005 to 2007 they said you know we don't
want to pay the extra bit to have flash
support so what kids do now is they have
a separate activity or terminal thing
that they can use to install flash but
it's sort of an unusual choice that
ended up hampering them later when stuff
like Khan Academy came out and then also
like the administrators want make sure
the kids are learning office apps so
they want to make sure they're using
word that kind of an Excel type app that
I helped write and presentation apps and
it helps to understand why they're using
Python Python this is like the Golden
Age of Python like MIT switch from
schemed using Python a lot of Java CS
programs were switching the Python
Google hired the inventor of Python said
this is the future of everything they
create a project wiki since every set
one said wiki's are a good way to
connect people they used get you know
kind of ahead of its time but you know
it's linux distro so they were using it
and though these things about the five
principles that people would probably
talk about at length I'm just going to
say they pretty much exist just to
insist on one laptop per child like
people were saying i'm going to buy 50
of them and set up a computer lab this
is unacceptable to the media lab vision
because they want the kid to thing
it's their laptop like it's their pencil
like why would they so when it starts up
it says what's your name and then that's
your name like it says Nick's photos
Nick's documents like they're very
actually trying to in a software and
operating system way encourage you to
just give this to one child and then buy
another one because that's kind of their
vision for the education and I think
today you see a lot of more interesting
ways of handling the puter labs this is
a project called keep odd where the
student has a live USB so it saves all
their software and settings and files
and the only cost is one USB per child
and then the computer lab can keep
running so I think this is a good way to
save your costs on the computer lab
anyway uh scaling up and down so or why
like I said is a national project they
had a very liberal government they were
very interested in this equality of
education between the cities and the
rural areas but you know right away
people say isn't this sort of a
political hand down for the party that's
in power right now so there's an element
of truth to that right I mean but people
would start criticizing is they really
want computer education or do they want
votes but at the same time if I go to a
school in Uganda and just me the teacher
and doing like a pilot project doing
some research you'd say oh that's
impractical that will never scale we
can't send Nick to every school in
Uganda which is again true so it turns
out whenever you launch your own
education project doesn't matter how you
approach it someone will tell you oh
that's not how it really works but
that's how it gets started that's how it
could start happening I think they also
didn't really expect the internet to
move so quickly so many people are 3g
now even going for Africa South America
a lot more internet but also they just
never expected there to be such quality
high speed internet I think Khan Academy
one of the top countries it's used now
is India so people over there are
already learning using computers and
they don't need to have this whole work
around getting a special device ah in
recent years this is in this interesting
movement towards JavaScript both in our
real world and server-side code and also
in this edge
asian world so the people who worked on
sugar labs have adopted a project called
sugar riser this is a web-based HTML
java SE 205 JavaScript app and it works
in the browser there's an Android app
and all different Android app stores
that you can download and use the games
unfortunately you can't like open an old
Python activity file and click save as
javascript doesn't work that way so
everything's being kind of tediously
rewritten for this but it makes sense
they're keeping this sugar ethos of like
an interface that could be interesting
and easy for kids and remaking it for
the web the two programming environments
they had turtle art which is like a logo
programming and scratch have since moved
to the web as well so this kind of is
all these different activities that they
gathered and put on a laptop as
different native apps are moving towards
web-based tools and I mean it makes
sense javascript is pretty cool it moves
along with the web and the browser if
you have a computer that has a browser
that updates continuously and silently
kind of like google chrome i would say
device is secure and all the lessons
that you create will work on the next
device and the next device in the next
device you can write one lesson to have
it work on other places and that's
something that I think it took some time
for people to realize these open
education tools are going to get buried
if we don't make them based on the web
so what's going to happen next what's
gonna happen like not everyone's online
so this is a project that we set up in
Haiti I know it looks a little bit messy
but this is a solar-powered offline
server there's like this thing called
Intel nuke and so we put videos all your
Khan Academy videos your maps and your
different interactive things on there
and so you don't there's like 3G data
but it's very expensive so instead you
have everything saved on the server you
wrap it in bubble wrap you take it with
you to the school you charge it you
connect it to some car batteries like
this and it'll say charge and people can
access all those cool online resources
this is kind of a
gram of how that works so it would be
good to have all these offline online
resources that can be repeated offline
and one of those resources that we might
want to add is a way for people to learn
how to code I don't think that everyone
must code I don't want it to be the s80
coding thing but I do think people
should always have an opportunity to
learn how to code if they want to so I
get this question a lot what should I
teach my kid my niece my nephew and
we're not really though if you've never
been asked this or ask another
programmer this is kind of an unusual
question like you would think because we
know how to program we would know but
it's not so easy because I mean we're
here and if you ask around you'll find a
lot of people including myself here like
you know learn it themselves with the
help of their parents they know or like
they were like not like oh stop messing
with the computer they're like oh let me
help you I also know how to code you
know so see we come a lot of us come
from this position of advantage we don't
really know like it's not really about
us and how we learn how to code is like
how are we gonna get all the other
people who aren't here today all people
who said you know I don't get this and I
don't know who to talk to or like this
really doesn't make any sense or this
doesn't compile how do we fix that
environment so that people can learn how
to code in a more reasonable way I met
someone at UPenn and she said that she
learned how to code herself she went to
school there using scratch which has the
interactive blocks and she said it's
like a slap in the face she said I'm
like well I was nice to her at the time
but if I went back in time and came up
with this great come back and be like
it's not about you like you were already
learning how to code it's like when you
went to school if you learn how to read
and you have to learn phonics again like
it's not about you we're not sympathetic
that you have to learn phonics again
it's about everyone else everyone should
learn how to read and so we're going to
spend time on that and make sure it
works you think open-source onboarding
would be the easiest way to do this you
don't have to be part of a government or
a company you don't have to be old
enough to drive in order to participate
in an open source project but it's still
really hard to join an open source
project if I send someone to get up what
are they going to do there looks like oh
well they should download this text
editor and they should start running a
program and then do
get clone and there's things that people
don't know yet and even the whole idea
of open source is really weird to people
a couple weeks ago I was talking to a
cashier at the coffee shop I'm like I'm
going to Iceland anyway and I she was
like are you supporting like a brand or
a product I was like well well it's like
we write the code and then we give it
away for free and then I tell a story
about it later like you know people that
people are very surprised by this still
their projects but are Mary you should
be more projects that just accept all
the poll requests you can patch it up
later just so you know we're not
mission-critical if you want to
participate will merge your code and fix
any mistakes that come up so back to the
laptop so there's four things that were
stored on the laptop for teaching kids
how to code turtle art which is based on
logo etoys which is still really
interesting concept it's like each
object in etoys has own coding stack so
you can dry it make a little racecar do
something make another little car do
something scratch which I think many
people have seen which is also block
based and then pippi which is like a
Python interpreter came with some
different math games and like a photo
booth kind of application photo booth
application so it's kind of interesting
but none of them really like drew people
in as much as like turtle art and
there's some different schools of
thought on this some people were like
let's keep kids using turtle art let's
add blocks that control robots and
cameras and sounds and just write
everything in blocks why ever go to text
code so that's an interesting idea I
don't really agree with it but it's kind
of an interesting idea today there's
many different paths that people are
recommending there's block based coding
which we've been mentioning so this is
with code org and there are two things
that I like about this screenshot one of
them is we're not just using Turtles
anymore this is I believe this is elsa
from frozen someone who knows frozen
tell me so like it seems weird to look
at a Disney character to your your logo
program i'm pretty sure because of this
and they also have an r2d2 star wars 1
i'm pretty sure more people have learned
how to code using r2d2 and elsa then
in all the years that we've been
teaching people with coating with
turtles like it seems like a weird
compromise but it makes it easier for
kids to say I want to do this it's a
game has my favorite character in it
what I also like about this is with
blocks there's no syntax you don't have
to worry like oh I missed a semicolon
what I also like about this is you can
translate it into different languages
this is a Arabic blocks and they go from
right to left like when you switch
language they change the direction of
the blocks it's very clever and they're
actually a couple of languages that come
out recently kalbe which is Arabic Lisp
kind of language and pataka just came
out like in the last week it's like
Bengali language and scratch and Google
are kind of moving this forward they
have merged all the all the people who
are making these different block based
coding they have like one collective now
where they're going to make blocks that
work really well on tablets so that
could be really interesting in the
future there's also this idea of maybe
we could teach kids using games you need
a pretty high-end browser for this all
to work so it won't work on the laptop
but I'd really like if we did of
something like this because it's like
you have a spell book and you move the
character around you fight various
things it's not bloody or anything don't
worry like you could not going to like
be traumatized unless unless they miss a
semicolon then it might be charlton but
then also this is a part of iOS 10
Apple's can release something called
Swift playgrounds and there's like
little character and move around this
beautiful 3d world and apple is actually
going to do coding workshops at all the
Apple stores so it could be that in the
future you're going to meet people that
learn how to code using something like
this it's interesting it's a mix of
Swift which is a text language and it
has some kind of block intelligence if
you look at the bottom it's not very
visible but it suggests what you should
type you don't even have to type the
words you can click the suggestions and
then it'll fill out your program because
it's recommending what you should type
there's an idea that maybe we should get
rid of all the screens and have people
learn using robots this is a project
called bow bot which came out of
something called the ten-dollar robot
challenge I think
a bit more than ten dollars but it's got
some sensors it's got motors got power
this could be really cool to learn how
to code just with a physical thing I've
even seen recently there's something you
can there's like [ __ ] you can use
Japanese Canada to write programs now
gnarly sure how that works there's some
physical blocks that you can move around
to write a code and then also the
Arduino if you do anything with makers
stuff look up our do we know it's really
good device and then I think this is a
few years ago now have you seen the post
by Brett Victor worried dream where he's
talking about what if as you were coding
you saw the consequences of all your
decisions like all possible futures so
as you're writing a loop you see
different things being created and
uncreated so this very ambitious idea
there's some different gifs on his site
that explain it and the two kind of
projects that have gone forward with
this reactive programming idea one of
them is khan academy they have this
activity for kids where you write the
program and you do different graphics
and processing very similar to java
script and then you have instantly see
the results on the side and so you're
able like change numbers and see how it
would affect your program then there's a
pro an IDE that's going to come out
called eve which i think is supposed to
be for like grown-ups doing web
development and web apps I don't have a
screenshot of that it's still very under
wraps but the idea is that you'll be
able to see what your coding would
change entirely how we as developers
think about coding and then going back
to the interface and then going back now
if you're going to teach kids JavaScript
or if you're going to write your brand
new education app and JavaScript there's
like three risk factors that I thought
of just as doing one of them is
JavaScript could be replaced by some
future language to be determined you
know python made a lot of sense at the
time everyone was very excited
javascript is having that moment now and
is at a moment like are we at risk of
that there's also a risk that javascript
could divided into several
incomprehensible warring faction
mmm feel like that if you've seen some
different versions of Java Script you
might be a little bit more worried about
this and then throwing in there just for
fun there's risk that machine learning
could redefine how we write code and
what we're actually trying to write I
mean I've seen a lot of weird stuff done
with machine learning and does anyone to
openstreetmap what was it yes okay so we
always thought you know we humans would
pour over these satellite images and map
all the buildings of the world and all
its GPS and then they started having
computers look at it and they so it's
just for error correction and it appears
like yeah you missed one you missed this
one you missed this one like computer is
like this is so easy I can find all the
buildings like they're they look like
this so it turns out all the labor
intensive stuff that people have been
doing and mapping turn out to be really
easy for computers to do once they got a
good training data set so I wonder as
programmers if we have machine learning
look at front end development or like
wireframes going into HTML I wonder how
that's going to turn out in the next few
years another thing I want to mention is
I have this whole thing today you're
supposed to clip it on to your baby but
I got one because I poured the
Kickstarter as this thing called
Starling is not a step counter it is a
word counter so there's this research
that kids who hear more words I get
better vocabularies and do better in
school so the obvious solution is to
make a microphone and clip it on to your
baby and it's this really cool device
I'm not really sure where this is going
to go but I like it because you know
it's there's no screen there's no like
we're going to teach the kid this or
that it's just saying like we should
have metrics and sensors that let us
know are the kids learning what are they
learning what should they be learning is
very early stages i think if you gone
into this field people would believe you
whatever it was that you said and then
you would get some really interesting
results um looking forward like what are
what's the if you were starting a new
organization One Laptop Per child 2
point 0
what are you gonna do so I think you
don't focus on the hardware of the
browser you say whoever you are whatever
computers are available to you if
someone donates you them to you it's
fine just get me a computer with a
browser on it like we really really want
on top a child focused on the whole
thing from the hardware and the
operating system and the education tools
really just focus on some people are
going to get kids computers with browser
some people are gonna give them the
internet and then their resources like
Khan Academy and there's a group library
for all that does I books and they can
set up something on the web and will
work anywhere and when you do that one
thing that one laptop per child messed
up is their hardware they agree not to
sell it outright in the u.s. because
they want to get the lowest possible
price they don't want to compete with
other suppliers but if you look at Khan
Academy they're getting a lot of funding
and interest because it's used in the
United States it just happens that it
works really well in other countries so
I think that's a good tactic if you make
an education library don't say this is
going particularly to this kid that
you've never met say I want your kid to
use this in school and I want the kid on
the other side of the world to be able
to log on and use this to ebooks are
still really hard if you go on Project
Gutenberg you'll find so many millions
of books but they're all very old
they're like dr. Dolittle when it was
racist there's like like French poetry
there's they didn't make kids books a
hundred years ago is the problem you
can't find good English content uh and
then local languages try to find
something in Haitian Creole there's kind
of a market now but it's very difficult
you like I have a friend who like knows
all of the publishers and talks to them
regularly because there's so few of them
so that's difficult to set up ebooks in
different languages and then also it
turns out a lot of times they deliver
the ebooks and the kids don't read them
I mean they have a computer like they're
not so I think if you had some way like
to engage kids more with the books or
found ways to make them especially
exciting or interactive in some way you
might get an edge but I don't know
another thing is making it available on
Apple
double server I showed that server
before that can work offline Khan
Academy is made offline using a separate
nonprofit called learning equality I
don't know if they even talk to each
other officially and then things like
co.org which has that block language
they've never considered making it
offline that's just their own website so
I think you need to look seek out
resources that you know have an open
source server somewhere that can be set
up somewhere else since we're all
programmers or programming environment
technical people i think if you want to
focus on computer science education
because it's something that you know
that's beautiful you should go ahead and
do it trying to make something that
works both at school like someone can do
like an hour of code with their kids and
just that's it but then also the kids
interested in they want to go home
there's like a self-serve like learn
what you will want to learn that's it
I'm Nick Doran if you've any questions
or really cool stories you can come up
if you haven't got a chance to play
around with the laptop like can you
bring the laptop up later and then we'll
we'll try it out i'll show it to you and
then i'm on map meld on twitter and on
github alright thanks